keine dieser schlagzeilen heute morgen
bei denen man denkt wie bitte
hollywoodstar alec baldwin erschießt
kamerafrau und das bei dreharbeiten zu
einem western in santa fe ja offenbar
war es ein tragischer unfall eine
requisiten pistole hatte wohl eine
fehlzündung der drehort auf der bonanza
creek ranch in santa fé wurde zunächst
gesperrt und die produktion erst einmal
eingestellt bei dem todesopfer handelt
es sich um die 42-jährige kamerafrau des
films halina hudgens der 48-jährige
regisseur joel sousa wurde bei dem
zwischenfall verletzt teilte das sheriff
büro von santa fé county mit hudgens
wurde noch zum university of new mexico
hausmittel geflogen starb dort aber
später an ihren verletzungen ja und sosa
wurde dann im christa saint vincent
regional medical center behandelt das
teilten die behörden mit zugeschaltet
ist uns jetzt sprengmeister sven
schrader von der thüringischen feuerwerk
schule
dienstleistungsfirma auch für special
effects herr schrader was kann da am
filmset passiert sein
humor
zunächst werde man betroffenheit zum
ausdruck bringen ist ein sehr schlimmer
unfall
das passiert in der regel auch nur sehr
sehr selten dass unfälle im zusammenhang
mit solchen dingen passieren allerdings
müssen wir jetzt abwarten was die
ermittlungen in den usa bringt es
könnten rückstände aus einer firma für
gewesen sein die aus geschleudert worden
allerdings aufgrund der schwere der
verletzungen und der
todesfolge gehe ich davon aus dass hier
entweder eine
falsche sache zum einsatz kam oder
entsprechend falsche munition verwendet
wurde die ist auch gar nicht dafür
gedacht war das wie gesagt muss man
jetzt einfach weiter und länderbehörden
wird
was heißt in diesem fall falsche waffe
was für waffen werden normalerweise am
filmset benutzt wenn das tatsächlich
echte schusswaffen oder sind das
eigentlich spielzeugpistolen
war spielzeugpistolen sind es in den
seltensten fällen die meisten sind
spezielle film waffen das sind durchaus
auch scharfe schusswaffen die umgebaut
worden höchsten machern von fachleuten
die das handwerk auch gelernt haben so
dass man in der regel dort auch keine
scharfe munition geladen kann mit einer
waffe die tatsächlich auch scharfe
munition verschießen kann wird selten
auch im film gearbeitet allerdings dann
nur von speziell ausgebildeten leuten
die auch entsprechende war schon
rechtliche genehmigung dazu haben und
die fachkenntnisse sollte war von wissen
speziell gewartet werden und es bedarf
einer enormen fachkenntnis die waffe
entsprechend vorzubereiten für die
filmaufnahmen hier gelten besondere
vorschriften der im verfolgungs
gesetzlichkeiten her was müssen
gereinigt werden dass da noch ganz
spezielle munition verwendet werden bei
der munition die möglichst keine oder
kaum rückstände hinterlässt und dann ist
es auch noch eine frage der distanz zu
den darstellern ob da nicht auch noch
unfälle passieren könnten also selbst
mit der besten film munition und kapuzen
munition kann es passieren dass so
kleine verletzungen auftreten aufkommt
von
tieren die dort heraus gesteuert werden
können aber das ist hier in diesem fall
wahrscheinlich nicht passiert man kann
jetzt eine spekulieren beste hintergrund
ist so wie das aussieht wird hier mit
sicherheit ein ganz grober fehler
begangen worden seien schade es gab ja
einen ähnlichen fällen zwar mit dem sohn
von bruce lee dem kung fu darsteller
brandon lee ann sonders war 1993 gibt es
da parallelen beschreiben sie nochmal
den fall von damals auch
in diesem fall 1993 das ist ja auch
bekannt hätte sich wohl um einen
rückstand gehandelt da noch im lauf
eines revolvers verhandelbar welche
waffe dort genau zum einsatz kam kann
ich ihnen leider nicht sagen wir wissen
wo das war ein revolver eine ganz
tragische geschichte und
dort hat sich im lauf in rückstand
gefunden der tatsächlich durch eine
platzpatrone der abgestellt wurde dass
der schauspieler den verletzungen dann
relativ schnell erlegen ist also durch
innere blutung in diesem fall es ist
doch zum tod gekommen auch hier muss man
sagen dass die wahl von definitiv vorher
nicht ordnungsgemäß vorbereitet wurden
die waffen meisterteam filmstar
verantwortlich sind für solche
schusswaffen sind natürlich auch
gehalten ganz extrem strenge kontrollen
durchzuführen und die wahl von modernen
aus der hand zu geben wo dort
einzusetzen wenn man sich absolut sicher
ist dass da nichts passieren kann und
ich denke mal das wort ich auch
vernachlässigten ergebnis das uns diesen
personen sagen gibt es da
unterschiedliche sicherheitsstandards in
europa und den usa denn wie wir alle
wissen sind die waffengesetze in den usa
ja nun ganz andere als hier bei uns
das ist vollkommen richtig hier muss man
natürlich auch sagen dass wir europa
ganz andere gegebenheiten haben auch der
gesetzlichen basis das ist hier
wesentlich ausgeschlossen dass solche
unfälle passieren das waffengesetz in
deutschland zum beispiel ist eines der
restriktivsten
welches wort kind und die dkv
vorschriften die im zusammenhang mit
waffen bei darstellung russischen gas
genommen hier
zugrunde liegen sind auch sehr sehr
sicherheitsbewusst gefasst und ziemlich
streng ausgelegt so dass man davon
ausgehen kann es ist in den usa
etwas lockerer zu sprechen ist das
natürlich auch ein schock für alec
baldwin selbst da in so einer situation
plötzlich die kamerafrau zu erschießen
werden die schauspieler für den umgang
mit solchen waffen noch mal speziell
geschult oder wie muss man sich die
situation am set auch vorstellen ist da
der aufnahmeleiter der sich die waffen
noch mal im letzten moment auch noch mal
anschaut und checkt
in der regel ist es so dass man am set
den lochen resta hat also eine
verantwortliche person die speziell
geschult und ausgebildet ist und auch
für die waffen verantwortlich ist und
diese person hat die waffen unter
verschluss und wird sich vorbereiten für
den film braucht eh und je nachdem was
uns je gefordert ist entsprechend
präparieren und dann den schauspieler
natürlich auch ordentliche diesen
gebrauch der waffe einweisen also
zumindest es hier bei uns ist es üblich
weiß nicht wie es heute gemacht habe ich
denke das wird ähnlich gehandhabt dass
die darsteller selbstverständlich im
vorfeld eine ordentliche einweisung von
der verantwortlichen personen anreisen
die waffen werden dann übergeben das
werden wohl auch von beschlüssen
durchgeführt ist nur dass man hinterher
sicher sein kann dass auch der
darsteller in der kopf die situation der
airport eine wartung der hand hält weiß
was er tun es werden sicherheitsabstände
festgelegt und das werden auch prozedere
für den notfall festgelegt und das alles
ist aufgabe dieser person die dort wo
auch dass er verantwortlich für die
waffen ist
[Musik]